and when I see you all I hear is Angela
Bassett did the thing I mean you got a
kick out of that you were training for
days a big cake big cake it's wonderful
it is it's so cute Jamie Lee you are all
of us this is why I 100 understood what
Ariana Dubose was rapping when she said
Jamie Lee you are all of us I think
she's all of us I think she is so
fantastic and I I I really don't
understand the whole thing and I think
it's just BS I think it's a terrible
disservice to her great talent but she
will so I don't even know what anyway
don't get me started that's okay you're
a genius well I'ma let you go Bobby
remiss not to say Blanchard Kate you are
a genius
[Music]
Jamie Lee you are all of us
foreign